hey guys I'm Ryan Wright today I'm going
to be checking out this video
asdf I don't know if that's an actual
word as movie 1 through 8 the complete
collection go you knows look out he's
got a nose you gotta help me man my tie
is evil and it's gonna kill me please
don't hurt me
hello parking meter hello hey hey guy
hey smell my flower mmm a menthol what
the hell's wrong with you
Oh save you
tree powers activate yeah die potato mmm
YUM ahh why would you do this I have a
wife and family thing it's unbearable
what am I to tell my children I love
them
oh hey you know who's gay you oh come on
I baked you a pie
oh boy what flavor pie flavor I like
dancing
I like trains hey
it says gullible on the ceiling oh sorry
doll you stole my lungs no not today ha
ha they said I could never teach a llama
to drive no llama no
doctor I think I might be a homosexual
how can you tell hey what are you a man
or a mouse hey kids I brought you some
cookies I like trains come on there how
did I get here
the end ha ha I can't read kitten fight
no wait I'm allergic to adorableness ha
what are you up to son I like trains ha
ha yes you do
hey you know who's gay I can't wait to
eat this bagel yes you can
yeah I guess you're right oh no I
spilled my milk you killed us all who
parked their car on my sandwich oh I did
why will this damn fax machine won me
paper are we there yet
ah yes yay ah crap hey man look at my
new dog oh yeah that's pretty cool
ah there's no dog there
Oh Joey did you eat my sandwich
I am your sandwich well here hold this
Thanks
screw gravity goodbye world okay Jim
I'll see you around where you going No
Oh No oh that's not right thought he
meant by that at all huh there's
something on your face it was pain
watching your god now son don't touch
that cactus you're dead to me
honey why is the baby on fire buy me
more jewelry don't even think about it
hey guys check out my new camera oh wait
this isn't the camera die potato I like
trains
oh no no no way I'm gonna do it Internet
well I'm gonna do a book Oh
sideshow piano ideal was there oh hey
kid you can't skate here you can't tell
me what to do I want to be a PI nice hat
Thanks I was being sarcastic well I
stole your face I need my new shoes you
are a chair darling I can dream Harold
it worked my time machine I am A
Stegosaurus quick shoot me in the face
you'll get mugged kid no you're getting
mugged how does that even work
hey son catch notify the cheese why wait
hey Bobby
play that one about bond down the stairs
ciao Ange I love it
so beautiful out here yeah it's just me
you and the moon hey you do should kiss
sir you appear to have a very severe
case of baby voice hello mine turtle hey
Manuel play some video games no way dude
you always beat me no oh okay
oh man you ever gonna run out of muffins
no because I walk is he muffin duck toy
come on my pony can fly and now Ducks I
was just about to say that we are so in
sync here all this I'm gonna put you in
the face but it's opposite day
oh oh no I am NOT stepping on you you
ever get tired of being random me
neither
I'm going to punch your face in the face
camera better cut hello and welcome to
standing up school and you fail hey you
got a license for that you'll never take
me alive knock-knock who's that got door
hey did you know that carrots are good
for your eyesight you lied to me hello
Oh No
Oh puppy Oh careful honey
he has a knife I had no no idea I'm
gonna do the flop
hello Berger I used to be a cow Oh
and now the funniest thing you've ever
seen
for really far away he's a magical pony
to the sky on a magical shoot it down I
have no idea how to breathe what are you
drawing honey I'm drawing a bear Oh
quick don't think about cats here comes
the airplane is anybody here a doctor I
am well you're a nerd hey what'd you get
for your birthday I got older oh that is
weird
hey you want to play catch the knife
show Mom I suck at this game ma'am I'm
afraid I caught your son doing homework
where did I go wrong
hey Joey you want to eat me no thanks
mr. muffin but I want a guy hey Stacy do
you want to go to the prom with me I'm
sorry but I'm a ghost but you're not
dead bye Brian hey buddy you want to
take this outside
sure Wow what a lovely evening this is a
really good idea don't jump you have so
much to live for
everybody's a flop Oh so fall yeah
whooping no okay baby are you an angel
I'm allergic to feathers
you're fat yeah I am a very tall [ __ ]
hey buddy turn that frown upside down
okay Desmond the moon bear the end have
you seen the baby no I think he got
outside you fool
yeah yeah yeah yeah I am depressed
suddenly pineapples this does not help
hey buddy look over here ha ha oh you're
blind what's going on guys nari this is
an intervention you need to stop
breaking people's necks what are you
talking about
Larry what Larry hey cool hat
no Susie don't look at the road I am A
Stegosaurus
happy birthday it's a boy invisible
billion [ __ ] hey Bill and catch the
frisbee Billy sir I'm afraid you have
brain cancer
suddenly pineapples well the good news
is you don't have brain cancer anymore
save me super guy No
you're dead hey Apple Apple Apple hey
Apple well we failed don't look honey
hello mine turtle Oh suddenly pineapples
he's a magical
I love it
hey you know who's gay my baby but
mother I love him
stop trait of backstories when did this
all start well hey what time is it
actually it's 12:30 miss you need to pay
for your food no put it Oh Timmy don't
cry
seriously Timmy cut it out today this is
the worst day ever
and now a cow pretending to be a man
Alan are you a cow
what no yeah me neither you guys want to
go skateboards my boyfriend said I'm the
most beautiful girl in the world who did
it my boyfriend said that too there can
be only one fellow giant flying sheep
those are clouds you're leaving me sorry
Eddie I've met a real man hi babe yes I
am real man you want to go skateboards
you're adopted you've done kids get off
my property
knock knock who is that a mirror I am
lonely would you like to see a magic
trick no oh look at the little baby
oh and now look at the big baby whoa
your fans they're all dead
what kind of man would do this ski ports
all right well I didn't find that like
uproariously hilarious I still did enjoy
that a lot
yeah like for the most part it was funny
it was inventive I actually found myself
admiring it more than I was laughing at
it mean for starters like I mentioned
this in another video my favorite kind
of YouTube skits are those ones that
really feel like spontaneous and I feel
like with the jokes they come up with
with little skits they come up with it
sounds like people are just like making
a play on phrases or common sayings and
then they flip it and add a like some
weird twist to it I feel like those are
people who are not sitting down being
serious about hmm what should be the
twist to it I feel like that it's just
something they say to each other and
then they come up with something strange
and then they go for it another thing
that I Meyer about it too is like same
thing I feel when I watch like cutaways
on Family Guy or when I watch The
Incredibles they really do stuff that
can only work in the medium of a cartoon
like if this was real life it'd be weird
it might be disturbing even but with a
cartoon making it black and white was
actually a really smart maneuver it was
good for those few color jokes not like
making fun of black people in the 50s I
mean like it's in color and it made me
interested in like seeing like what
would this look like in color would this
be funnier would this not be as funny
it's weird how adding color to it could
actually take away some of the humor but
I would be interested in seeing a whole
segment that is all in color and it
might be distracting because there's so
much visuals going on but in black and
white it does work well but I really
think that they should do a few that are
just simply in color yeah I really dug
it that was fun and I'd be glad to watch
more if you guys are new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rechecks
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter where if we get
enough followers we can get product
placement that's right and I'm hoping to
get sponsored by sweatpants sweatpants
are great you can go anywhere in them
you could work out in these sweatpants
and let's face it if you're in jeans and
then you're about to have sex
someone then they start taking off your
jeans it can be a real hassle like it
doesn't feel good you got to like push
it with your feet and it's really
annoying
as opposed to sweatpants these are easy
to take off you can start putting your
penis in that woman's vagina or mouth or
butt sweatbands this is my superhero
underwear arvin mazui hey guys i watch
your videos all the time stay awesome
and keep uploading you guys make my day
thanks Arvind mazui Arvind MS Obi is the
name of a vehicle that was invented by
Armenians it was a BMW model you know
Arvin Mazzoli was just a little too
towards Armenians it wasn't worldwide
you know like it came with some glasses
it came with gel slick your hair back or
a razor to shave your head came with
really baggy clothes chains a hookah
pipe it was it was just not good but
Arvind my Zoe you stay classy and thanks
for the support my friend
oh yeah and Arvind the Zoe also came
with a bunch of really hot big nose
Armenian [ __ ] who for some reason are
dating like really ugly looking Armenian
guys but hey that's what they do trust
me I've tried [ __ ] an Armenian chick
before it does not work